hallo herzlich willkommen zu salehs welt
heute gibt es kleine apps weil wir jetzt
gerade ganz viele äpfel zu hause haben
und ich werde dafür einen teig
zubereiten das ist ein tag der den
nötigen ein bisschen ähnelt aber er ist
stadt möge er etwas knuspriger und vor
allem hat man eben keinen zucker mit
drin dass er am salz ich würde schon
sagen wo er neutral
früher hat man den immer gemacht um zum
beispiel passierte neben zuzubereiten
aber man hat die kosten nicht
mitgegessen sondern das war eher die
hülle für die füllung und heute ist man
natürlich die kruste mit und das ist
auch eine ganz lange geschichte aber ich
bin ganz froh dass es den teig gibt und
deswegen werde es erstmal den teig
zubereiten uns sage ich die zutaten für
den teig braucht 225 gramm enthalten
teelöffel zucker enthalten teelöffel
salz eineinhalb teelöffel öl das kokosöl
115 gramm 1 kalte butter 30 milliliter
kaltes wasser und einen teelöffel essig
oder zitronensaft so da ist es ganz
wichtig dass die zutaten ganz kann
zubereitet werden und am besten eignet
sich auch eine küchenmaschine dafür oder
ein handrührgerät mit den händen geht
zwar auch aber der teig sollte wie
gesagt nicht warm werden jetzt gebe ich
zuerst einmal das mehl in die
küchenmaschine und ich mach das jetzt
mit den mixa da kommen jetzt salz und
sogar mit dazu und das ruhig jetzt alles
kurz mal ein
jetzt kommt das kokosfett mit rein und
kokosfett ist bei raumtemperatur oftmals
sehr flüssig ich habe es jetzt aus dem
kühlschrank ausgenommen und das werde
ich jetzt auch das einholen
als nächstes gebe ich die butter in
stückchen mit dazu und die hatte ich
gerade noch für ein paar minuten im
gefrierschrank also die darf wirklich
eiskalt sein geht es ganz wichtig dass
ich jetzt nicht einfach nicht weil dann
der teig eben warm wird sondern ich habe
hier in meiner küchenmaschine so eine
puls taste das heißt ich gebe immer ganz
kurze impulse und der teig wird um kurz
geknetet dann hält die maschine wieder
an und dann immer weiter bis die butter
nur noch in kleinen stücken zu sehen ist
jetzt ist die butter nur in kleinen
stücken sichtbar
jetzt kommt das eiskalte wasser und
essig oder dass der zitrone und das will
ich auch noch kurz mit der puls taste
eingerührt
den teig schütte ich jetzt auf die
arbeitsfläche und ihn dann mit den
händen ganz schnell und kurz zusammen
das gebe ich zum teig in eine schüssel
decken ab und stellen für mindestens
zwei stunden in den kühlschrank man kann
den teig so ist auch ein fred und dann
bei bedarf einfach immer wieder auftauen
in der zwischenzeit kann ich jetzt schon
mal die füllung zu bereiten ich mache
das eine absolut füllung und für die
füllung brauche ich drei äpfel ich habe
zwei elster äpfel eine unbehandelte
zitrone 50 gramm zucker 20 gramm
puderzucker 25 gramm stärke einen
teelöffel zimt eine prise salz und etwas
muskatnuss jetzt zuerst einmal die äpfel
die sind leicht säuerlich deswegen
eignen sich hervorragend zum backen und
die werden jetzt erstmal geschehe
kennt ihr das auch als kind habe ich
immer versucht diese schlange ganz lang
zu machen
oh mein gott ich schaffe es kommt nichts
wenn du es dir ausmalen kannst und dein
herz daran glaubt dann schaffst du es
hier
die äpfel werden jetzt geviertelt
entkernt und dann werde ich sie fein
würfeln
die äpfel sind jetzt gewürfelt und die
werde ich hier mit den restlichen
zutaten vermischen
da nehme ich jetzt die unbehandelte
zitrone und reife die gelbe schale ab
das sorgt und für ein richtig tolles
aroma in den endpreis
mit zitronen bis ins quetschen und dann
den saft auspressen
und eine fräse muskatnuss und es werden
die zutaten verrückt und dann muss ich
nur noch auf den teig warten
derzeit ist jetzt gut durch gekühlt und
ich habe ihn jetzt einmal kurz
durchgeknetet so lässt es sich besser
verarbeiten und jetzt rolle ich ihnen
etwa 2 bis 3 mm dünn aus
und jetzt nämlich einen runden
ausstecher man kann auch zum beispiel
ein glas nehmen und der ausstellung
sollte ein bisschen größer sein als die
mav in form die er verwendet
und jetzt schlechter kreise aus
jetzt nehme ich die mav in form und
fette sie mit back transparenz und da
lege ich jetzt die kreise rhein
da kommt jetzt die füllung mit reinen es
deutlichen bruch förmchen
den restlichen teil habe ich jetzt noch
mal dünn ausgerollt und den werde ich
jetzt in 1 cm breite streifen schneiden
das geht entweder mit einem messer mit
pizzaschneider oder mit einem bissig
letzter habe ich gleich fünf klingen auf
einmal
schneidig die streifen mit einem
ausstecher in form
und zwar habe ich dann einfach schon mal
die perfekte größe und das ist jetzt ein
etwas kleinerer ausstecher der etwa so
groß ist wie die machen einfach jeden
zweiten wegnehmen
dann habe ich jetzt die längs und quer
streichen
die ränder bestreite ich jetzt mit einer
mischung aus einem ei und einem
esslöffel milch und dann kann ich das
hier gleich drauf legen
die querstreifen werden jetzt hinein
gelebt das heißt dass hier einmal hoch
und da hat man einmal dem streifen
drüber und einmal drunter
also entweder machen das jetzt so und
weise noch einfacher haben möchte kann
natürlich die streifen einfach ohne zu
weben übereinander legen also unten die
längs- und obendrüber die querstreifen
oder macht ganz anders in dem tier 4
teig streifen und könnte es muster
bereits hier schon geben und zwar
mehrere auf einmal und dann schlecht es
aus und legt es dann drüber
die mini fx hab ich jetzt noch mit der
einmischung bestrichen und so werden sie
jetzt im vorgeheizten backofen bei 180
grad ober unterhitze für etwa 20 bis 25
minuten gebacken
wir sind jetzt neun stück daraus
entstanden aber je nachdem wie ihr sie
oben gestaltet entstehen neun oder zwölf
stück
die ffs sind jetzt gebacken und ich
hab's ja auch ein bisschen abkühlen
lassen und wer möchte kann sie jetzt
gerne noch mit süßem schnee bestreuen
ihr könnt natürlich auch puderzucker
nehmen aber puderzucker schild mit der
zeit und sie so schnee bleibt ganz
einfach drauf liegen und ich würde
empfehlen die teilchen mit süßen schnee
zu bestreuen
denn sie sind ja an sich gar nicht so
süß sind wir haben eigentlich nur süßes
in den äpfeln und ansonsten ist total
care relativ neutral noch ein bisschen
drauf und verbraucht auch keine und
täler und keine gabel dazu man kann sie
ganz einfach aus der hand essen
den habe ich jetzt schon gegessen und
man sieht auch ganz toll die füllung
dies sehr saftig und der teig außenrum
wirklich schön knusprig und ich finde es
ist eine tolle idee wenn man sie einfach
mal mitnehmen möchte als fingerfood oder
einfach eine party zum beispiel ich
hoffe ich habe euch ein bisschen dass
das schmackhaft machen können und ich
wünsche euch ganz viel spaß beim
nachbacken das rezept findet ihr auf
meinem blog auf salehs - blog.de und ich
wünsche euch ganz viel spaß dabei bis
zum nächsten mal
hauptsache herzlich nach im video